now in this country we're talking about
a major overhaul of a program that wipes
out student loans that could help more
than a million borrowers the education
department said yesterday it will relax
its rules for public service loan
forgiveness it's a program created to
reward college students who decide to go
into public service their student debt
is erased after they make 10 years of
on-time consistent payments however the
program's rules have been criticized as
too complicated cbs news business
analyst jill schlesinger is with us now
joe good morning to you so this was
meant to help people but it wasn't
helping people what's changed now well
you know since 2007 the inception of
this plan it has been notoriously
difficult to navigate complicated opaque
and in fact 90 of the people who
actually applied got rejected and that
meant that only 5 500 of 5500 borrowers
got that student debt wiped clean now
with these new rules the government is
saying that they're hopeful that 550 000
more people will be in the plan okay
what made it so complicated it was the
department
so it was not just paperwork but you
know the plan was created so that anyone
who would say a teacher a nurse a
a service member someone who worked at a
non-profit you had to have that first
part you had to be full-time but then
there was this other couple of hurdles
one was that you had to make continuous
payments for 10 years some people missed
a payment here and there new servicers
came in and the other piece was it was
the type of loan that you had so under
these new rules what the government is
doing is basically temporarily relaxing
some of their rules
retroactively and this is going to allow
many more people to have those loans and
those payments counted towards being in
the plan so i know there is gray area
but who qualifies well i mean again
full-time and you know teachers nurses
service members you work for a
government a state municipal federal
government member but the reality is if
you don't really know if you qualify if
you have federal student loans and you
work for a non-profit or in one of those
sectors you should go to
studentaid.gov because there you're
going to be able to register if you
haven't been registered already but
there's going to be a lot more
information most of this should be done
automatically according to the
government so they're looking for ways
to include people instead of exclude
people could it signal more changes in
the world of student loans yeah well
we've heard about 10 to 50 000 of debt
being erased for every borrower well the
white house has kicked that back to
congress i think we know that congress
has a lot of other things on their plate
so if you have a federal student loan
don't count on forgiveness right now
keep making those payments when they
start up again in january
all right joe thank you very much